Hi, I'm Anna Miller,...
...and I'm Skye Flanigan.
And we're from Harvard C-CHANGE.
And here are three reasons to be optimistic about climate change:
Number one: We're seeing huge innovations in climate solutions.
Our dependency on fossil fuel is going down rapidly.
Last year alone, we've cut our consumption by 13 percent...
...and we're on track to do the same this year.
And renewable energy like wind and solar is becoming cheaper than coal...
...in a lot of places in the U.S.
Number two: We're seeing a drastic shift in public opinion.
From 2014 to 2019, the number of Americans who felt alarmed tripled.
So, that's actually really good news...
...because it means people are learning more about this issue.
They really care about it...
...and they're starting to understand how it affects them personally.
Number three: Local governments are taking action.
Just recently, Virginia and Oregon both committed to 100 percent clean energy.
Over 445 mayors across the United States...
...have committed to staying in the Paris Climate Accord.
Climate change has been portrayed with a lot of doom and gloom...
...but it's also the greatest opportunity we have...
...to reach a healthier and more sustainable future for everybody.